[Applause]
it's exciting
spirit award for best editing goes to
joy mcmillan for zola
[Applause]
sorry
um
for um for a second i had no idea what
was going on um
i thought we were at a commercial break
but i get it um
um i would not be standing here without
janix bravo
i can't
um
her tenacity her fearlessness
and her purpose to tell this story
with such heart
with such humanity and with such
authenticity is something that i'm so
proud to be a part of um so thank you
janixa for saying yes to me when a lot
of people said no
um
i would be remiss if i didn't um also
um say thank you to the other person who
said yes to me what a lot of people said
no um an up-and-coming filmmaker barry
jenkins
i don't know what happened after
moonlight but i hope you're booked and
busy
to the zola family thank you thank you
thank you so much
coleman domingo taylor page nicholas
braun riley keough
jeremy o'haras ari wagner nika levy
katie byron
killer films a24 gigi films i hope i
didn't forget anybody thank you all who
oh my gosh
asia zola king
thank you so much for your art
[Applause]
and to tell it so well woven with such
humor and the way you processed your
trauma will live on through this film um
i always said that i would never ever
forget to thank
my siblings
uh derek darren jennifer jessica and
gian thank you so much for teaching me
about cinema even before i knew what how
it was made thank you so much for
um
giving me the ability to quote willy
wonka
every line of it because we watch it so
many times
my underground family i know i'm winning
this for zola but i remiss if i didn't
thank you plan b
mark syriac our lifeline and phone a
friend everyone else thank you so much
[Applause]